barbara hat vor jahren ein schema
entwickelt zu aktivierungs methoden das
haben wir beide in den letzten jahren
verfeinern und das möchten wir euch
heute gerne vorstellen
es geht nämlich darum dass wir in kursen
immer wieder die also oder immer wieder
haben wir das thema das natürlich in
lehrveranstaltungen nicht nur 90 minuten
lang ein import vortrag kommen sollte
sondern dass die studierenden immer
wieder zeit zwischendrin brauchen um das
gehörte um den input zu verarbeiten und
durch kleine phasen der rechtes
nichtstuns oder den etwas anderes tun
oder durch die interaktion einfach
wieder zurückgekommen ihren fokus wieder
finden und auch ihre aufmerksamkeit dann
wieder zurückbringen
also eigentlich wissen wir dass wir
möchten den lehrenden didaktisch
sinnvolle planung von
lehrveranstaltungen an die hand geben
und einerseits weist jeder mensch ja das
unterstützen lernprozess das hilft den
studierenden beim reflektieren die
aufmerksamkeit ist wieder da aktivierung
hilft einfach dass ich auch tiefen
orientiertes lernen fördern kann
andererseits das kennen wir alle aus
unserer praxis wir haben viel stoff und
wenig zeit und wir müssen die inhalte
vermitteln also auch danke wenn ich
dreimal eine aktivierung mache ist es
vielleicht schon da vielleicht eine
viertelstunde mal ganz schnell weg
so also hört man immer wieder das heißt
wir haben mangelnde zeit in vorbereitung
und durchführung wir scheuen uns
bisschen vor passive studenten wenn wir
studierende wenn wir sagen so jetzt alle
mal aufstehen aktivieren das denn die
meisten sagen aber ich kann es nicht
mehr hören also das mache ich nicht mit
wir haben fehlende ideen bei lehrenden
auch mitgekriegt dass die gar nicht
wissen welche aktivierungs methoden denn
genau auf ihrem fach kontext passen und
das letzte ist ein vorbehalt der sowohl
auf studierenden als auch auf lehrenden
ebene war das doch aktivierungs methoden
als recht albern handy bekommen
und dem wollen wir mit diesem schema
begegnen und
die operationsmethoden versteht
danke ich kriege ja das ist gut aber das
hat
okay was wir oder auch in die literatur
und aktivierungs methoden verstehen
meine kurze definition und bevor jetzt
auf die definition eingehe ist ganz
interessant ich habe echt gesucht was in
der hochschullehre runter aktivierungs
methoden verstanden wird und ich habe
ewig gebraucht was zu finden also das
meiste ist irgendwie nur im schulischen
bereich was dann in diese problematik
der albernheit oder der nicht
ernsthaftigkeit geht und ja in der
hochschullehre ist irgendwie gar nicht
so widergespiegelt und was ich gefunden
habe ist so der bezug zu ok es gehört
nicht so wirklich zu den
lehrveranstaltungen ist wird immer mal
soll immer wieder eingestreut werden und
es ist so nettes gelegentliches tun oder
pädagogisches mittel und dient so ein
bisschen so zu gruppen zusammen führung
zur spann entspannung ermüdung cent
scheidung oder aber auch und das fand
ich schon die gehalt folgten aspekt der
konzentrations förderung aber wie
wichtig die aktivierungs methoden sind
wird eigentlich kaum in literatur so ein
bisschen auch widergespiegelt die hat
auch irgendwie finden und und für uns
oder er für euch auch diese tat machen
was will jetzt darunter verstehen oder
worauf wir uns jetzt genau beziehen sind
einfach methoden die kurz sind die
inhaltlichen bezug haben können aber
auch nicht unbedingt also dh wir haben
keinen zwingenden inhaltlichen bezug und
das ist das schöne die brauchen kaum
zeit zu verbreiten die kaum mal
einstreuen zeichen der vorbereitung
seiner durchführung weil er wie gesagt
was die jahre gesagt haben viel stoff
wenig zeit auch gerade im vorlesungs
charakter muss man mal was machen und
man denkt jetzt muss ich die mühle was
in schwung zu kriegen also die sollen
nicht viel zeit kosten es ist für die
studenten eine kurze pause und kann wenn
man jetzt einmal eine vorlesung denkt
als einstieg oder nach einer längeren
konzentrationsphase eingesetzt werden
aber auch wenn man jetzt an der
blockveranstaltungen denkt man
meine studierenden kommen jetzt nach der
mittagspause wieder und setzte sich erst
mal hin und dann denken sie wie kriege
ich sie denn jetzt wieder aktiv also da
ist es ideal
wichtig ist man muss sich wohl dafür
wohl damit fühlen wir haben auch oft wie
gesagt das problem da ist das nicht
einsetzen weil sie mit widerständen von
den studenten rechnen und das ist wohl
das größte haben das überhaupt beim
einsatz von der lernmethoden weil sie
sagen wenn man studenten das nicht
möchten ich fühle mich da so als
animateur und ich fühle mich da nicht
wohl und es muss passen und das muss
auch zur kultur passen also in manchen
bereichen sagen sie meine kollegen
machen es überhaupt nicht wenn ich das
jetzt ein sehr willig total positiv
formuliert die orchidee in meinem fach
und das möchte ich nicht also ich muss
mich damit wohlfühlen
also muss schauen welche methoden zu
einem passen genau und um dann nochmal
bitte darauf einzugehen weil es uns auch
wichtig ist warum die so in teilen
sondern worum die gefördert werden
sollten
oder warum man sich überhaupt damit
gedanken machen sollte kurz noch mal
kurz darauf ein
genau kurz der nutzen daher danke also
einfach noch mal kurz zusammengefasst
was
hallo
was wahrer auch schon eben ein bisschen
erzählt hat ich finde es ganz gut
aufgelistet eben das aktivitäten der
also die studierenden in einer aktivität
einzubinden fördert den lerntransfer
nach kino wir wissen alle dass eine
wiederholung oder wenn ich zeit habe den
stoff zu verarbeiten dass die behalten
leistung fördert es unterstützt die
aufmerksamkeit es ist motiviert eine
motivation aale komponente es fördert
die lernatmosphäre dieser austausch ich
habe ein gefühl dafür wir sitzen
eigentlich neben mir ich traue mich dann
vielleicht auch später noch fragen zu
stellen wenn ich ein gefühl für die
gruppe habe und fühle mich nicht ganz so
anonym und studierende lernen auch in
pausen nicht viel aber auch da tut sich
weiterhin was auf der anderen seite was
nützt es denn und dozierende es gibt
ganz große effekte dass wenn studierende
untereinander gut arbeiten können dass
sich auch das verhältnis zum dozierenden
verbessert dadurch oder dass auch das
vertrauen und die hemmschwelle was zu
sagen und mit dem zu interagieren viel
besser gegeben ist also bessere
voraussetzungen und pause fördert die
community wie entlastung das heißt also
ich bin nicht die ganze zeit auf
hochstrom sondern ich habe dann auch mal
zeit kurz mich zu sammeln und zu schauen
wie geht es denn jetzt eigentlich weiter
in einem stoff also aktivierungs
methoden haben sehr viele vorteile
hier und da zu sein sondern viele mail
archivierungs schema methode ausgedacht
welt ist jetzt behalte ich behalte
und das ist noch zwei dimensionen
kategorisiert und ersten dimension sieht
man so die inhalte das heißt man muss
schauen inwieweit möchte ich methoden
einsetzen
14 großen betrug zoom eine
lehrveranstaltung haben oder ich sage
ich mal was komplett fern ist
und auf der anderen dimension haben wir
das thema ernsthaftigkeit also möchte
ich eher was machen wo ich sage das ist
sehr ernst ich passt vielleicht auch
besser zu meinem thema oder aber ich
habe eine blockveranstaltungen ich
möchte jetzt aber mal was humorvolles
machen und vielleicht auch ein bisschen
die gruppendynamik zu fördern dann guckt
man mehr in die richtung also wir haben
jetzt vier quadranten wo man die
aktivierung methoden einsortieren kann
um dann einfach zuschauen was passt zu
mir und das passt auch zu meiner
lehrveranstaltung um dann nochmal die
ziele kurz einzugehen was bedeutet ist
also wenn wir sagen dann innerhalb neue
methoden was fördert das also es ist
einfach wichtig für den lerninhalt man
unterstützt die studierenden beim
reflektieren und dem wiederholen
wer jetzt sagt ein bisschen fern vom
inhalt was hat das für ein ziel das ist
so schöne auflockerungen entspannung
muss einfach nicht zum lerninhalt zu tun
haben und es tut den studierenden auch
teilweise sehr gut
ernsthaft die methoden zur wiederholung
oder auch eben für konzentrations pause
und ja die humorvolle methoden wie
gesagt muss zu einem passen muss man
schauen ob man sich das zutraut gerade
in größeren gruppen aber ich kann nur
sagen es funktioniert
die dänen einfach so der auflockerung
auch zum spaß und zur auf die quadranten
noch einmal einzugehen also wenn man
jetzt schaue ich bin dozent und was
möchte ich dann erreichen bei meinen
studierenden
wenn man jetzt sagt ich möchte einfach
die behalten leistungen unterstützt und
ich möchte den lernprozess fördern dann
schaut man eher in den ernsthaften
inhalts ladenbereich akzeptieren die
studierenden vielleicht erst mal
leichter gerade wenn es darum geht auch
eine gewisse leere kultur zu etablieren
weil man sagt okay ich konnte meinen
studierenden während des semesters ganz
klar die vertragen auch mal
so etwas humorvolles und ich möchte die
motivation fördern geht man einfach ein
bisschen mehr die richtung wenn ich
jetzt sage oh ich bleib lieber
ernsthaften bereich möchte mal was
inhalts fernes ausprobieren einfach zur
pause zur entspannung kann man aus dem
quadranten was sich raussuchen und wenn
ich sage okay fern vom inhalt darf
wirklich auch nur in die straße richtung
gehen darf man auch einfach nur mal ein
bisschen auflockern und wir haben ja das
ist das schöne daran heute jetzt schon
beiträge gehört wo es schon darum ging
mal kurze aufführung zu machen und jetzt
ist so die quizfrage bitte also ein buch
ab
dass man dass ich mal was vormachen den
100er zone nach einem foto nach dem
mittagessen serbien dass die leute alle
man aufstehen müssen und einfach mal nur
wieder sozusagen in gang kommen diese
bewegung ist wichtig was der vub und ich
fand es super dass diese puppen an wie
man es hört sich halt genau man jetzt
machen wir einen boom aktiviert bei dem
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
vorfall und inhaltsleeren auch der und
salat
wunderbar wer ist also immer wenn man
eine kleinere gruppe hat sich auch
genannt ist es so dass die besten drei
sätzen es gibt eine spur weniger als
teilnehmer einer steht in der mitte
ziehen ist
halten er sagt dann zum beispiel alle
leute mit roten gürtel oder wie auch
immer müssen es dann versuchen sich zu
ergattern musizieren und je nach boden
und schuhen
wir haben noch den rassen wird das
papier fällt diese vorne und warum 62
dazu kann es oder dann werden wir decken
mit fragen von allen eingesammelt
entweder konkret zum stoff oder auch mal
was ganz anderes
oder müssen wir drei diese moderieren
und beantworten das ist ziemlich
unterhaltsam weil einfach auftragen um
die sonst keiner rausstellen würdest du
angekommen
mit sehr gut und da war noch eine 3 wir
haben werden und machen das sich im raum
aufstellen muss auch immer jemand da
nach unseren in die anordnung muss
diesmal stellt mit seinem vorbildlichen
klima oder irgendwas herausforderung
mein chef damit kann die nadel wird uns
mal aufstellen zum kennenlernen nach
himmelsrichtungen
also mein geburtsort oder ständig neuen
heimatorten
die verwendeten richtungen dazu
das tool ist
humorvoll und ich komme hier ja wenn man
sagt die große feuer vor wüssten nicht
ob man sagen
weihnachten das ist ja auch richtig cool
wir müssen die schritte zusammen gehe
zwei gruppen die müssen sich drei
geschichten erzählt und über sich selber
wurden muss ich sagen einige blumen
geschichte erzählen und vorstellen wir
haben fast gelungen
es ist aktivieren
nur gucken wie lange zeit dauert aber es
ist auf alle fälle aktivieren sehr gut
und man simoni also die ganz stärken am
besten suchen hunger dann ein kleines
gebiet was diese die schüler weg treibt
niemand hier ist inhalt angekommen den
windows
nimmt das langsam und alle ist alles
klar
[Gelächter]
dankeschön
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
und unterhalt
bitter klingt macht immer noch
unglaublich an die tafel geschrieben
ich habe jedes einzelne mal traf in der
schule lassen weil es einfach nicht gibt
es innerhalb asiens trinken aber es ist
wirklich ist mag einfach klingen aber
einfach nur sagen gesteht mal aufläuft
nicht die fenster wir machen den
haltebereich teilweise schon komplett
aus hause eine ernsthafte und inhalt war
methode hatte er auch vorher im vortrag
vorgestellt das war ich kenne nur
plusminus fragen aber er hatte die
englische bezeichnung ja genau also ist
es so eine richtig schöne ernsthafte
inhalt neue methode und auch der erasmus
hatte vorher ballspiele aber ich mit
speed dating geht auch in die richtung
natürlich ist wahrscheinlich humorvollem
inhalt kombiniert aber es geht genau in
die richtung wie gesagt muss man einfach
dann gucken wie wir die zeit dann noch
zur verfügung steht weiterhin geht
entweder da oder in richtung wollen mit
paper also ich kann euch ja mal ein
beispiel gleich nennen also wir hatten
die vier jetzt ist eine exemplarisch wir
haben ein richtig schönes sammelsurium
also was vorhin auf gesagt wurde war
geboten aufstellung ich hab das mal in
ernsthaft kommt natürlich auf die
fragestellungen drauf an also wo man
sich im raum lokalisiert one minute
paper geht in richtung free fighting
aber mit mehr vielleicht eine
fragestellung oder mehr mit dem
inhaltsbezogen zu einer der effektivsten
methoden um inhalte
ja zu behalten also wenn man sich
einfach hinsetzt und die aufgabe bekommt
ihr schreibt man alles was ich bis jetzt
in den sinn bekommt also ist ein
unglaublich großen effekt zusammenfassen
lassen oder auch mal kurz plötzlich das
alleine reicht schon aus um die
studierenden dann einfach wieder zu
aktivieren wenn ich jetzt in den zweiten
quadranten gleich weitergehen da hatten
wir auch gerade diese denkpause was
vorher genannt worden
man kann wie man sich auch damit wohl
fühlt mit den turinern versagen und
jetzt dient oder streckt euch mal kommt
ganz drauf an power napping eine minute
pause sie können gern die augen
schließen und dann klingelt ein lauter
wecker und manchmal ist man dann wieder
hellwach er sich im raum bewegen lassen
oder stimmen spricht im übungen kommen
ganz auf das thema darauf an also vor
einer klausur oder vor irgendwie nach
stressigen zeit man sagen jetzt
beruhigen sie sich schauen sie mal das
jemals zu sich in sich hinein spüren
oder was man alter noch immer machen
möchte in die humorvolle ecke gibt es
auch unterschiedliche möglichkeiten
jegliche quiz form also ich hatte einen
so zieren denn der hatte seine vorlesung
am freitagnachmittag und die motivation
der studierenden gegen immer so ein
bisschen in den keller
und er hat wirklich das wer wird
millionär ist quiz etabliert nach jeder
stunde er hat der vorgefertigte folien
und das resultat war dass die
studierenden wirklich auch für das quiz
mit gelernt hat er hat da nette gruppen
ziehen lassen hat fragen ziehen lassen
hatte dazu auch noch soundeffekte es war
vielleicht ein hauch übertrieben aber es
war wirklich eindrucksvoll und das macht
spaß auch dieser wettkampfcharakter
und ich kann wie gesagt nur sagen wenn
man mit irgendwelchen extrinsische
motivation mitteln sei es schokolade
oder was auch immer lockt die
studierende machen sofort mit also ich
hatte ein beispiel auch beim thema super
experte wir hatten 80 studierende in der
dozierenden oder studierende ich weiß
nicht mehr genau aus dem bereich
maschinenbau und die waren sehr
skeptisch gegen die didaktische
fortbildung haben wir mit denen den
super experten gemacht und die haben
wirklich einen richtigen
wettkampfcharakter also am schluss
standen auf haben dann irgendwie
versucht die fragen richtig zu
beantworten also klar man muss ich vorne
wohl fühlen und die gruppe im blick
behalten aber es funktioniert ganz gut
super experte ist würden also stehen
alle auf und man hat fragen die mit ja
oder nein zu beantworten sind und man
gibt die anweisungen beim ein sollen die
studierenden die arme kreuzen und bei
jahr die arme hoch man zählt dann bis
123 und sondern sich für eine frage
entscheiden und der der fall schlägt
setzt sich hin und dann bleibt am
schluss die
eine person oder die personen stehen die
hat dann alles verbockt habe am schluss
ist so der tipp möglichst schwierige
fragen zu stellen damit dann irgendwann
auch vorbei genau
noch fragen dann wäre so das letzte ich
muss sagen ich mir macht's persönlich
immer viel spaß aber muss ich wohl
fühlen ist so obstsalat wurde genannt
dann kam man powerpoint karaoke auch
schon mal erlebt dass einfach folien aus
irgendwelchen sitzungen aufgefüllt
werden und die studierenden aufgefordert
sind jetzt einfach mal und wenn es
falsch ist es das ist falsch wenn sie
nicht komplett korrekt ist das zu
wiederholen dann diese ganzen klatsch
klopf übungen
das ist sehr spannend finde ich auch
gerade aus dem interkulturellen kontext
also da habe ich mit teilnehmern zu tun
habe die aus zum beispiel in
afrikanischen ländern zu tun kann man da
ist es viel etablierter und was die
mehrzahl weise für sachen beigebracht
haben es ist wunderschön und da ist
weiter zu tragen an die studierenden
hier aus münchen macht mir besonders
viel spaß also weil es einfach ein jahr
man lernt hat dann auch aus anderen
kulturen noch erkennen oder halt im
samurai sein beispiel also geht es viel
um man muss personen nach machen und
dann irgendwelche figuren nachmacht ich
habe jetzt hier sein moral genannt weil
man irgendwelche proteste in samurai
oder tier oder was man auch immer machen
möchte
nach macht und dazu ein spiel kreiert
und man kann viel machen wie gesagt man
muss sich aber wohl dabei fühlen das ist
so das aller aller wichtigste sonst eher
in dem bereich bleiben gerade wenn man
respekt vor den widerständen vor den
studierenden hat wenn man die gruppe gut
kennt ist es kein problem
frage inwiefern hilft jetzt dieses vier
felder schema oder drehen und mehr
aktivierungs methoden einzusetzen und
die akzeptanz dafür zu fördern baurecht
es sich einfach nur liste und dann auch
jemand ein problem das eingetreten was
nicht die barbara untersucht gerade auch
am land der theorie des geplanten 30
jetzt für diese eine folie die anhand
der theorie des geplanten verhalten von
eiser und fisch wein untersucht sie
gerade den lerntransfer und das finden
wir auch eine schöne verknüpfung zu
diesem vier felder schema da geht es
nämlich darum wann mache ich eigentlich
was und wann verändere ich mein
verhalten und adaptiert ein neues
verhalten also da muss einiges
zusammenkommen die kultur muss stimmen
oder es muss zur kultur passen meine
einstellung muss stimmen
die situation muss passen da sind also
einige aspekte und wir finden dass erst
mal dieses vier felder schema einem
hilft dass man die persönliche haltung
zu aktivierungs methoden reflektiert
also ich kann gucken das alberne ist das
was für dich für mich passt es überhaupt
oder bin ich eher der ernsthafte typ zum
beispiel ja genieße ich das wenn mal was
inhalts fernes ist oder sage ich ich
brauchs inhalts na wo bin ich wohl
lokalisieren ich mich eigentlich wo
gefällt's wieder am besten dann kann ich
als zweites die zielgruppe analysieren
was erwarten sie von mir was brauchen
die was haben die vielleicht auch in
anderen veranstaltungen so dass wir das
gut darauf abstimmen wie die kultur ist
wir können die nicht überfordern denn
die es gewohnt sind in ihrem
bachelorstudium wochen monate ein
semester lang input vorlesung zu kriegen
und einfach sehr passives verhalten
haben denn glaube ich über fordern wir
die wenn wir dann plötzlich ankommen mit
alle zehn minuten bisher eine
interaktive methode und das ganz lustig
und dreht euch mal im kreis und schläft
mal kurz machen
da müssen wir ganz vorsichtig ran passen
und auch das hilft einem das zu
analysieren und die zielgruppe daraufhin
zu einer wehr zu analysieren
das zweite ist die anpassungsfähigkeit
an die fach kultur auch da kann ich
gucken was passt gut zu meinen inhalten
was kann ich nehmen was passt nicht so
gut
endlich ist das fließt es hier ganz gut
alles ineinander über ist nicht so
trennscharf ja also wir finden das für
felder schema ist eine wunderbare
grundorientierung um zu sich und für
seine situation und für seine lehr
kultur die passende lernumgebung
clippers eine aktivierungs methode
auszuwählen mit euch diskutieren wenn
ich natürlich auch oder wie gespannt
sind
inwieweit dieses vier felder schema sinn
macht also wir möchten dass aktionen
würzburg für die das team zur verfügung
machen also es geht so in richtung die
methoden des schreibens also haben wir
schon mal ein bisschen angefangen so die
idee war so eine karteikarten
sammelsurium und man guckt einfach in
diesen vier felder schema was brauche
ich denn gerade wie ist meine situation
um dann einfach zuschauen
also ich kann man beispiele nennen also
das wäre so einen workbook beispiel wenn
man sagt ich habe so viele studierende
so und so viel zeit ich möchte aus
diesem bereich eine methode anwenden wie
gehe ich denn davor dass wir auch so die
planung dann in bezug auf moritz aber
wie gesagt das macht nur sinn wenn wir
sehen okay das geht sich aus oder das
macht auch wirklich sinn
also das war so die idee oder auch eine
frage an euch
inwieweit ihr da fällt mir die frage die
ich einen aber inwieweit so quasi das
durchaus sinn macht so eine art und
weise eben methoden zu systematisieren
und weil wir finden also dass nach
diesem schema kann man ganz gut methoden
auswählen
es sind eben auch ernsthafte methoden
dabei um auch dagegen zu wirken das ist
alles nur albern ist und spielerei und
die studenten das sowieso nicht
akzeptieren wichtig ist dass es wenig
zeit kostet also es und auch
vorbereitungsaufwand also so klausur
fragen kann man eine idee aber
idealerweise sagen eine stunde sammle
ich mit den studenten welche klausur
aufgaben oder nächsten stunde nämlich
sie als quiz oder das von manager bei
jeder hat ein blatt papier und stift vor
sich also soll nicht wirklich viel
aufwand bedeuten aus dass ich eine frage
vielleicht zu überlegen und auch dass
die durchführung leicht ist also manche
methoden sind ja sehr komplex in der
ausführung aber ich brauche irgendwas
druck anwenden kann wenn ich merke dass
motivationsloch ist vielleicht aber die
aufmerksamkeit ist gerade nicht so da
grau oder wenn ihr sagt mensch das
brauche ich unbedingt noch das muss in
so ein katalog mit rein dann werde es
auch auf alle fälle hilfreich dann wäre
es die aktivierende seite so von uns
vielen dank